in this tutorial i'm going to give you
tips on how to pose men hi my name is
gerry guinness i'm a wedding portrait
and fashion photographer i've been
shooting for 27 years
and teaching for 20. in this tutorial
i'm going to give you tips on how to
pose men we're going to teach you how to
go from this
to this by the way i had this amazing
course the portrait quick start
click on the link below to
camera they don't downl like to be
photographed nowhere near as much as
girls
now what he's doing naturally he's
putting his hands over his crotch
which tells me that he's covering up the
most sensitive part of
his body now body language will suggest
that he's feeling uncomfortable not that
he's feeling uncomfortable but he's just
waiting for a photograph
also he's sort of parting his feet now
personally i actually don't like it when
feet are parted in for a guy especially
see here's what happens
curves define the female form as far as
the male form
chest and shoulders define the male form
now if you want to emphasize something
you push it towards the camera and
towards the light so in this case for a
guide the chest and shoulders will be
great towards the camera
and also the waist further back we'll
come to that in a moment and as far as
the the feet are concerned
we have to understand that posing starts
from the feet
okay even if you're photographing head
and shoulders we have to actually
begin to understand what's happening
here because that'll affect what's
happening over here
so i often think of posing like
architecture that we've got
peaks and valleys so if curves define
the female form
as far as the male form if he's standing
up straight like this
there is just nothing going on there's
no peaks and valleys this
we often refer to posing like letters
here is just an
i there's a line and a dot nothing but
what i want is i want a v
okay we often talk about that strong v
particular look and feel so here's what
happens
if we turn his body on a bit of an angle
my suggestion is most of the time
now here we've got the lighting right
over here most of the time you want to
turn the body
of the male form towards the light so
posing is not just
understanding posing you have to
understand posing according to the light
source
so if a light source is over here this
is going to make him look bigger and
broader even if he's wearing black in
this case
so now what's going to happen is even
though he's turned his body towards the
light
i want to do this i want to put your
feet together like this
now put all the weight on your back leg
and just bend that knee
perfect and now put your hands in the
pockets right like this
okay so remember if you're wearing a
jacket with two buttons you always do it
up and you never do it up
so that just gives you a bit of room to
breathe now i want you to hang your body
and do a glorified slouch
that's it let's relax too much there we
go and now turn your body a little bit
towards the camera so now as you can see
what we've got is a v we've got peaks
and valleys even that slight little bend
is bringing this
in if this looks thinner this looks
wider
now here's the before and after by the
way this is jacob i call him a disney
prince
and this is a normal 47 year old
australian greek american dude okay
so right now he was like this the
difference between this and this is just
is ridiculous of course i'm handsome in
my own way but uh he's got the dimples
to die for is that all we're saying but
anyway like this is fine
but again you can't compare it with a
shot like this this
makes him look more casual think of all
the male icons that we actually have
seen
uh in in in the movies like marlon
brando hanging on the bike think of
james dean sort of hanging on the on
that sort of that piece of wood there i
think east of eden sort of thing
what i'm getting at is guys in many ways
more than one
like to hang okay i'm not gonna go down
below but let's we like to hang this is
part of what we do as men
especially with this case okay so now if
you've turned your body like this
and you're turning your body towards the
camera we are looking a lot better now
what i want to do too now is just let's
just reset let's unravel for a second
and i want to show you guys the easiest
way to pose anyone
let alone in this case we're talking
about posing tips for men and that is
this
simply get your subjects to mirror you
so if you stand a bit more that way okay
all right perfect so right now let's say
for example now jacob we've only met
once before
we have not done a little tutorial
beforehand you don't know what i'm going
to do
but if i said simply to you just mirror
exactly what i do
just copy exactly what i do as if you're
looking into a mirror okay
[Laughter]
so what we've done now is we've quickly
proven
with a bit of a wink and a smile that
posing and actual posing and getting
people to mirror you is the easiest way
for someone
uh to understand posing let alone to
communicate it and if you attach a
humorous thought to it so i just did the
good old john travolta sort of up and
down and finger up and down
now i've sort of stopped demonizing
posing he's more relaxed with it so when
we talk about posing we often
think of it like posing being a dirty
word it is not a dirty word it is simply
bringing out the best in someone
so whether it's a girl or a guy or
whoever i'm photographing i'll establish
this
i'll say as handsome as you are i can
make you shine brighter than ever before
with a simple direction would you like
that
absolutely that's it it's important that
whoever you're photographing to
understand that posing is actually going
to bring out the best in them
and actually a really important part of
the process so if we stop demonizing it
now we can work together and we can
actually make it less taboo and then
have some fun
so what do we do with hands i believe
hands are the most expressive thing
after the eyes so we have to use them
wisely now here's the problem here's
what a lot of photographers will do
to their subjects and in fact they won't
do anything just do what you want
now if you put your hands in your
pockets naturally how would you do it
so maybe just undo that so you would say
this is quite common
so here's why this is a problem now in
my opinion
these little fingers look like two
little penises coming out actually
pointing to the real thing
and this is not a really good thing so
now that i've told you that you're going
to be conscious of it for the rest of
the time we shoot
and you don't want that okay so this is
now body language would suggest that
this is actually quite a relaxed way of
photographing a guy
but it's not aesthetically pleasing this
is even worse we're framing
the boys right now we don't want to
frame the boys we actually want to just
put the hands in the pockets either in
or out
now especially if you're actually just
wearing pants like that it either has to
be in
or out if you're wearing jeans you can
do the good old
relaxed fists and all that kind of thing
and that's totally fine so really really
important
hands in or out and let's just go back
to the jacket being done up
so if you're wearing a jacket so put the
hands right in
okay so nice and relaxed very good and
then we sort of drape that over and
again this button is undone
now don't forget of course you can
actually combine the poses so let me
explain
see if you over pose a guy he's going to
look a little bit feminine
and that's going to be an issue so my
suggestion is if you put a hand in the
pocket and want to do something else
well see
give him something to do what else can
he do with his hand well let's just copy
what i'm doing
so let's say one hand the pocket and you
can put one hand holding the jacket
yep you can put both hands holding the
jacket you can adjust your watch because
that's what you would do you would
adjust your cufflink
you would just roll up your sleeves you
would also maybe just put your arms and
arms crossed see
if you're working with someone like me
i'm a tall guy i'm six foot two but i
have very very small arms
right so here's what i would do for me i
would get my fists put them underneath
my biceps
and then i would just bring that down
and then it makes the biceps still not
look so big
but that's where you can liquify the
crap out of it afterwards in photoshop
on both sides
but yes that's a good way of doing it
naturally if you were to relax
most guys will do this they'll put one
one hand in
and one hand out how do you do it
naturally without thinking how do you
cross your arms
okay so you do it the big way so he's
got small arms as well he's hiding small
arms there but
like this is fine see if you do this for
a guy it looks feminine we don't want
that so
one hand out will actually make that
look masculine without it looking
feminine
or we do this if you want to look a
little bit bigger and bulkier remember
too
we are never going to be straight and
flat-footed we said that's a wrong thing
that's not going to work well for a lot
of people so we said let's combine these
ideas now so we're going to turn our
body towards a light source in this case
an open garage door
we are going to hang the body a little
bit more forward we're going to slightly
sort of bend that knee so shake the feet
out sometimes we can overdo it
okay so bring the feet together don't
think about it okay bend that front knee
hang the body and then lean the chest
forward so now we've created that v
let's go a little bit a little bit
taller basically depending on the body
type and the body shape and the face
is how far you go with that particular
pose so for example
let's say we have plus size guy
and again he was setting up two straight
like this his guts hanging out
there's double chin showing we don't
like that well in this case
we're going to lean him way forward and
then chin forward
almost like a turtle so if we basically
look out that way for example
now i want you to pretend like your your
head's like a turtle and do this for me
okay i am serious there'll be times
where i actually do that over and over
dramatize it
but i'll crop the awkwardness out
because right now if i just do
this it looks stupid you can tell that
i'm doing it but the minute
my face overlaps my neck a little bit
you can't tell what's happening
we call that for shortening we're
shortening the length of a body part in
this case
the neck looks a little bit weird so we
just relax it a little bit down
and it looks awesome so remember
for a guy especially wearing a suit just
give him something to do
no matter what the occasion for guys
they like
this idea so put the hands in the
pockets bring the shoulders up
bury your chin underneath the jacket for
example chin down a little bit there you
go
and then turn like this how cool does he
look just there
let's come back here a little bit so
don't forget if you're actually
photographing a plus-sized guy
you're actually getting to emphasize the
pose that we did before
so for example if we turn our body
towards a light source like we did
before
put our feet together but by the way
remember we never want to get
what we call pigeon toes i don't know if
we call that in the same thing in
america you guys call that the same
thing yeah okay
you don't want pigeon toe that just
looks weird okay basically draw an
imaginary line between
each toe and we never want the imaginary
line to ever cross over so at the very
least we put them parallel
i personally like one foot just a slight
bit of an angle
so for example i just get people to
shake it out put the feet together and
then slightly bend that front knee
okay of course with women you will over
emphasize it and do it a different way
which we'll cover in a different episode
but for now let's just relax again bring
the shoulders there hands to the pockets
just for the sake of the argument
and then turn the shoulders towards the
actual camera and
now we are looking at a v now how much
you lean
forward or as i say glorified slouch it
depends on the person
so for example if we had a plus size guy
where we didn't have
much of a neck we didn't have a
narrowing point you would need to sort
of stretch that face as far as possible
so bring the shoulders back
and then bring that chin forward now
that looks weird from this perspective
but what happens is depending on your
angle you can shorten the length of that
neck
by simply going up a little bit higher
no different than
let's say for me for example if i point
my
my hand towards the camera here then all
my hand and my arm are actually covered
in a circle but in fact it's actually
that long
so with posing and with compression and
whenever you're photographing people you
do not want to foreshorten
any kind of body part within reason
based upon the shot that you're looking
for
but that can also help so deliberate for
shortening can actually really really
help
so let's do it again so we're doing like
this
and then chin forward now he doesn't
need it he's got a sharp jawline young
dude no problem
me i've got to sort of do that turtle
thing a little bit too
if this looks awkward you're going to
bring the camera angle a little bit
higher
and then make sure that sometimes in
fact i often get my guys to lean forward
like this
it might look great three-quarter or
close-up but it's gonna look really
awkward full length
and that's where i simply don't shoot
full length in that capacity
so remember all these posing tips are
great but it really depends on the
person that you're actually
photographing
as to how far you go or not now that
we've established
some posing tips for the mail form let's
put into practice and take some shots
so now jacob's looking very
uncomfortable his hands over his crotch
he's got a part between his legs he's
just waiting for some direction
pretty much how most guys will be in
front of your camera so yes we have to
disarm them with charm and fun and humor
and all that kind of stuff
but for now we're specifically talking
about the nuances
of what will bring out the best in the
male form so we said
that we want to turn the body towards
the light source in this case
the garage door is open so we're going
to turn his body
towards the garage door great so now
we'll put your hands in your pockets
just to give you something to do guys
feel really cool when they when you've
got your hands in the pockets
remember we do not want the thumbs
coming out so
in fact let's try let's try a few bad
versions of what we're doing
so straighten up this way again hands
over the crotch
and just looking over here great what i
want you to do now is just simply put
your
hands in your pockets and with your
thumbs it's like
so like that perfect so looking at me
just normal passive face
great now do this okay
we do not want those shots okay let's
look at them again
hands over the crotch no thumbs out no
and then thumbs in the pocket and all
the four fingers out no we don't want
that
so now we are going to turn the body
towards a light source make him look
bigger and broader so let's turn your
body towards the light so stop there
too much just come back a little bit
good now if ever
sometimes what happens is when you're
asking a guy to turn his body towards a
light source
he'll do this and keep his feet planted
so often what i'll do is i'll say to my
subjects pretend like you're on a turn
table
and i'm rotating you this way that way
basically your feet your legs
every part of your body and your person
is moving towards a light source so in
this case he did it right
so now put your hands in your pockets
and if your legs are feeling a little
bit stiff i
always ask my subjects to shake their
legs out a little bit great
okay feet close together and now simply
just bend that front
knee good hang the body forward
glorified slouch it's a misnomer
that posing um and that a guy
should be perfectly straight like this
we said at the introduction of this
video
that we get double chins and get a bit
of a gut so if we now
have a concave version of our upper
bodies
then we're going to get the the gut
further away from the camera and the
chest and shoulders towards the camera
in this case you can see very clearly
what's happening
now his feet are there you can see how
there is a a
valley in his legs which makes it more
of a v but we're going to actually get
him to turn his body more towards the
the camera perfect and then tilt face
this way and turn
do me a favor just bring your elbow out
a little bit on this side too much just
come back a little bit
good a bit more and then bring this arm
out a little bit too
so more back so just lift up the elbow a
little bit
now why we're doing that is that i
actually want to see a gap between his
arms and his body
not always in this case i find that if
you were photographing a mere mortal
like me
now i wouldn't call myself skinny i
wouldn't call myself sort of
ridiculously overweight i've got normal
chubby issues at 47.
what i want to do is i want to have gaps
between body parts that give me a
silhouette
and also if i bring his arms out apart
from seeing a gap as we can see here
between his arms and his body we
actually broaden him still
so if we now bring this elbow out a
little bit good
and then turn your face this way turn
good and eyes back at me
and now we're looking cool and if ever
you feel
that your subjects feel a little bit
stiff in the shot because you've posed
it a little bit too much per se
i might say to this jacob just let the
air out of that shot
perfect so now it's looking really good
turn your face
perfect so again let's look at the
difference so now we've got
peaks and valleys the chest is quite
wide we're
going right down to the v of his legs
and he's looking bigger and broader and
it's a bit more refined
for photographing a guy look at the
difference between that shot for example
and then posing the way we did it looks
nowhere near as good
so watch what happens now that if we
turn his body away from the light
as i would suggest the female form which
we'll discuss in a future episode
it actually makes him look a little bit
feminine and maybe a little bit too thin
and not as not as big and broad as we'd
like to see the masculine form
so now if we just get him to bring his
chin to his
outer shoulder and then his eyes back at
me
you can see how that just looks a little
bit feminine
and even if he leans towards the camera
let's do that again
that is a very very feminine pose we do
not want that
so if you over pose a guy you can tend
to make him look a bit feminine
and if that's your that's your
prerogative that's totally fine it
depends on what you're trying to
basically say
so remember posing starts from the feet
we always want to relax the feet we
usually want to bend the leg that's
closest to the camera
and all the weight is on the back leg we
want to hang the body
nice and relaxed turn the body towards
the light source
relax the chin bring it out a little bit
turn the
turn the face so this eye just
hits the light as we can basically see
now in this particular photograph
we hang his body we relax him a little
bit if we want to we can bring that
those elbows out a little bit to broaden
him a little bit even this one
good too much come back okay just there
and nice and relaxed we're not worried
about expression too much just a nice
passive look
looking towards that camera turn your
face towards me
and we have a nice finessed shot
guys hope you enjoyed that we'll see you
soon
thank you so much for watching hope you
liked the video and if so please give me
a thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
and hit the bell to get notifications
for future videos please leave a comment
so we can connect and i can answer any
of your questions
see you in the next episode and don't
forget you don't have to be the best you
simply have to be better than last week
we'll see you soon